and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review my life there's this
strange eccentric guy with a thick
accent and he travels all the way from
his country to oh and he makes everybody
feel uncomfortable hey oh wait a minute
I'm doing the movie for it
don't ever say to me it's never ending
but be doing who knows hey sorry let's
try this again tonight's with you this
is strange eccentric guy with a thick
accent and he travels all the way from
these country to ours and he makes
everybody feel uncomfortable it was
maybe isn't it stick there so the guy's
name is Bruno and I think he uh Street
and he goes round everybody asking who
are you wearing
nobody asked me that was cool are you
wearing and I said I'm wearing Franklin
the second Fraser and then he said what
about the pants and I said I don't know
what they're wearing and he was like
what about the shoes and I said they're
hushpuppy and he said they're made from
hush puppies I said no they're made out
of a bunch of a bunch of dogs were
bothering me so I beat the crap out of
them in turn the mrs. shoulders back
touch them up and then I ask the nice
man who are you anyway and he said his
name was Joan Rivers and he lived in a
box right next to me but I did Chris
that movie was awesome
why because a completion real situation
that's right real situation which is
funny because of that of the real people
are not being connected but it's all
real it's totally real
guy from Borat who's suing them because
he chased him around only cameramen in
the real world would know what corner
he's gonna turn so they can get all the
super big shots and everyone likes
missing the lawsuits are real they're
just doing it for publicity but I tell
you they are real I should know I try to
show up trying to steal my gorilla style
filmmaking except is actual gorillas not
easy actors so what did they eat all my
equipment and some feces at me it's tell
but I know guys tried to make his own TV
interviews Isis used to talk all the
time though we're not on speaking terms
oh come on it's not your fault that they
left but you should the way you were
born
anyway um I'm sure I can't take him
anywhere only mostly consists of gay
jokes and gay jokes things with the
house slowly falling into the clouds at
the old man and the little boy finally
Rick inside wait no that was movie up
who no just sending with monkey jokes I
love like knock-knock
I said knock-knock
boom oh don't cry you stupid
oh my god that is the worst thing you
ever said how dare you call me a break
you are scum Chester a bum and you're
going to help young doing you're coming
with me
no I'm not I'm going to penis heaven
where all the great geniuses totally
really yes all the right pieces are
there down at Teddy's Jack of it first
and even though it's women talking
probably penises or dude horrible they
had nothing to do with it there are many
ways to do good season did ya know this
game it is one sailor we found out about
the affair she did nothing it well it
was first degree penis ID so anyway
Bruno is again
my penis stop here summers talking penis
I've ever seen in my life
uh-huh this is history bouncing come on
say well it means a beginner castration
yeah I certainly won't if you keep it up